[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
week one is in the books I hope you guys
hit all your bets I hope all of your
fantasy teams did well man I had money
on the bills Lord looked after me I had
money on the Panthers not so much and I
had money on Detroit and that was one of
the biggest heartbreaks I've ever had in
my life
but the reason my heart is full is
because I'm not sitting in this studio
alone no I am joined by Brian [ __ ]
Westbrook let's go let's go brother
let's go two days a week from now on
pods that are coming out Tuesday and
Thursday talk about the biggest stories
the NFL breaking down what happened
getting a little in depth more in
stories I am so happy that you're
joining me man man I'm excited about are
you every time I catch you I'm like man
I got it I got a text left I want to
give all caps yeah yeah that's how I
that's how I text like hey yeah I'm
excited I want you to know right away so
let me tell you that I've started to
listen a lot more to Goggins I don't
know if you know who David Goggin house
like Navy SEAL his whole thing is I take
people's souls and that's why I texted
you that huh you texted me and I had
been listening to this dude and out
intense he was and you were like I'm
ready to go let's go and I sent you what
I was like we are gonna break everyone's
[ __ ] face right cuz that's how I want
to be that's how you should talk that's
how you should live your life actually
that's why I'm wearing camo because
we're going war Oh Brian Westbrook
missed so much to get into obviously we
are gonna be the number one podcast for
Eagles but really I have to start this
on Friday and Saturday because Friday
and Saturday was a Antonio Brown and
there's a million things to get into
with it I only want to do a little bit
but it is the biggest story yeah because
I watch the Patriots last night and I
went that team looks like the best team
in football and now they have a Antonio
Brown
all day Saturday how are you enjoying
the I need to be released video that
he's been released four o'clock on the
dot he's on the Patriots well here's the
deal I go to sleep Friday I'm going with
the kids on Friday night I'm exhausted I
fall asleep on the couch I wake up
around 1:30 in the morning Saturday
morning early and I see the video hey
man can we just focus on football stop
doing like he apparently recorded Jon
Gruden this is one of the best videos
that I've seen in my life well like I
mean this is a nice video if just do it
came out at the end yes great job
this is Nike you've done a great job
yeah this is a great video so I watched
the video I'm like okay they figured it
out they figured out how to make Antonio
Brown Jon Gruden the Raiders work
because Jon Gruden responded and said I
liked it he liked it man he had no
choice he had no choice so I was like
you know it's a little weird that he's
putting out a video after he got in
trouble earlier on in the week for the
fine letter but okay Jon Gruden likes it
I'm cool with it let let it let go
didn't as the day goes on I'm away from
the phone away from Twitter away from
Instagram and I'm like my boys are
calling me like I are you understanding
what's going on right now do you
understand when El Tonio Brown is trying
to do he's asked the Raiders to release
I'm like what no no I just saw the video
the himmat Jon Gruden are cool right no
more to the story
unbelievable I mean it's it's it's hard
to believe that all this went on within
a week I not even a week not even a full
week so four or five days what do you
think about the conspiracy theories that
Antonio Brown has been trying to do this
all along that Antonio Brown was trying
to go from the Steelers to the Patriots
and the Patriots made a trade off her
Steelers turned it down the two teams
that then came after him Buffalo he said
ain't no way in hell I'm going to
Buffalo goes to Oakland feet get burned
off I don't want to deal with the helmet
anymore yells at mike Mayock in his face
yeah
and calls him a cracker and he says
fined me for that and then punts the
ball and then we're sitting here and he
asked for his release he puts out all
the stuff he tweets and now he goes to
New England and he was a free agent at
four o'clock and he was signed by like
4:15 yeah what do you think about the
whole thing
this has been in the plans the whole
time to go to new English
IM a conspiracy theorist so i like a
good conspiracy theory i like that you
know maybe he's been thinking about this
the entire time but so many things had
to happen for this to actually happen to
me I asked this question I was asking my
boys this this is that question what
exactly does Antonio Brown want right
and this is before we all before all of
this went down what does he want well he
wants guaranteed money ok cool
well the Raiders gave them 30 million
guaranteed yeah now the way that it kind
of came out that is structured you could
find him a couple of times in the
guarantees go away I'll tell you this
they gave him everything he wanted you
had a coach that said now listen he's
going through the helmet stuff he's
going through the feet stuff the head
coach comes out and says hey man I
support them yeah I white one I'm here I
support them I you know I'll do anything
for them ok that's power in the NFL when
you're a player and you have the coach
in your backpack you're good Oh
usually only quarterbacks heaven that's
right you're good normally if you have
the coaching a back pocket
you're good then mike Mayock had a
doggone press conference and mike Mayock
and i give him some credit because
listen he ain't Tonio brown still isn't
one of the most talented receivers in
the NFL no doubt about it
big-time talent and you don't come
across that talent around the NFL all
the time mike Mayock in his first year
being Jim is like hold up timeout we're
trying to build a character we're trying
to be able to culture which I don't
build a winning environment we can't
have that and I'm sure he had to go into
John Green's office to say if you were
RPF you if you're serious about winning
you can't have that and then Jon Gruden
responds and if you're serious about
winning
I need a Antonio Brown that's right
because hunter Renfro can't be my number
two options oh and by the way you're
only here because I hired you so just so
you know don't don't forget that part
and and so I understand what Mayock did
because he makes sense make sense from
the Patriots perspective I will be
honest I [ __ ] hate this I hate this
because I like when Belichick has to
game plan against the best yeah this
feels as though it was kind of forced
and what I saw out of the Patriots last
night with Jacoby Meyer mm-hmm
and Josh Gordon looked amazing we're
done come fried Oldman and Sony Michelle
and James white and Rex Burkhead and
Phillip Dorsett and at first I went man
this sucks I already picked the Patriots
to win the Super Bowl I picked them to
lose to the Eagles yeah I pick them to
lose the Eagles but I look at them and I
go this is like worse than the Warriors
because Steve Kerr is not what Bill
Belichick is to football right like Bill
Belichick will win you six games you're
not supposed to because he's the
greatest coach of all time but what I
thought of after watching last night we
might need a Antonio Brown to be the
only reason this team it doesn't make
and mess the whole team up and a lot of
people they love to say you go there and
you bend to their will and you're not
gonna and I completely agree
if the Antonio Brown goes there and he's
tweeting and Facebook liveing after a
week or two and they kick him out
Patriots are gonna adjust and what we
saw on Sunday night it's all good right
but if a Antonio Browns there for 10
weeks
or 11 weeks and they start getting used
to him and they start building the
offense around him and then he implodes
because he really wants to do a
Christmas Day Facebook live or he really
wants to put out cartoons on his
Instagram or he wants to record Bill
Belichick calling him yeah please record
Bill Belichick calling you that might be
the only chance that the rest of the NFL
here's the thing I and I I said this
when Gruden brought him in I said we
Gruden that has had to have a
conversation with him that said amen I
need you to be a leader and actually he
did because Antonio Brown yeah and I
think you put this this dog on a video
out Antonio Brown saying hey I'm gonna
be a leader in a locker room of Hogans
accountable he went back and I found his
original press conference I'm gonna do
all these good things he said I'm gonna
hold people accountable if you're late
we're gonna find you dereck cars gonna
walk in here and go wow this wider seat
right he literally did the opposite of
everything he said all the things that
he said he was gonna do to the other
guys he did those things and he got
himself out of there so I mean if you do
any of those things and this actually
kind of caught me off guard too when he
put out the little the little it wasn't
a video but the that the picture of
business booming New England booming
whatever it is
that kind of surprised me a little bit
too because I in my mind Bill Belichick
said a man before you come here here's
the deal this is the law
none of those video crab none of this no
disrupting the team Tom Brady probably
said his little piece in a Antonio Brown
said okay that's what I'll do then the
whole little pitcher comes out so that
surprised me that that even came out
from someone in New England this is the
part that I you had that I gotta ask you
about is Antonia Brown crazy is he crazy
or is this an act because this is act
you turn to act on and off when he will
left Pittsburgh to Oakland my take was
incredible marketing by him and it's an
act the part that's making me think that
it's an act is the fact that he talked
to social media experts to figure out
how to get out of Oakland when he sent
that video reaction of him flapping his
wings and saying I'm free I'm free I
thought it's an act but I believe to
answer your question from earlier what
is Antonio Brown one I think Antonio
Brown has always craved control he was
on the cover of Madden like Patrick
mahomes and Tom Brady and he wants to
have the control of them he was always
second fiddle in Pittsburgh the quote
that I think sent him over the hill in
Pittsburgh was when the GM said we have
big bun Big Ben and the only two other
kids right right and he was like I'm not
one I'm Antonio Brown and then he went
to Oakland and mike Mayock said this is
my team I think a Antonio Brown wants
control now the question is is he also
and the controllers in this mind in my
mind is control of where he gets to play
and that's New England but to play in
New England you need to cede all of your
control you had all no control right
there is no freelancing it is three
steps and a slant it is not six steps
because you thought you had him deep so
um I don't know how it's gonna go what's
your well if he wants to control why is
he saying on the video with Jon Gruden
I've always I've shown you I've shown
you I've always wanted to be here I've
always wanted to be a rate that's just
want he just wanted to say that yeah
really you think so
I don't if I think that Antonio Brown
once he needs a coach to give him
control we never got it from Tommy which
I thought he would in Pittsburgh
we didn't get it from Gruden and when
Gruden didn't give it to him and Mayock
tried he bucked the system now he's
going to a situation where he will be
controlled it will have to work inside
this box will let you go on the edges of
the box will let you draw a little bit
outside in lines but however you need to
stay mostly in the dogon lines I believe
that I think that Antonio Brown likely
was a double agent no way always trying
to get to the Patriots but my hope is
Westbrook he's secretly a triple agent
and and that he's going to the patron
burn down to burn it down that's my hope
if if that had burst in the back right
now and he's a Patriots fan of the
Patriots fans out there now should take
all of this as compliments because we
all sit here
yeah the 31 other fan bases young NFL
yeah looking at you going New England
Patriots you are far and away the Super
Bowl favorites right now if we were to
end the season or you put a gun to my
head I'm picking the Patriots to save my
life
but the only hope we have is that xxx
Antonio Brown Vin Diesel goes inside
those walls as soon as it burns at all
well here's the other thing
yeah I don't think that's gonna happen
I'll tell you why I don't because Bill
Belichick says well one thing and you're
out of here oh you did something wrong
or you put out a message you take me
when I'm talking to you
you took my conversation outside these
walls in your gun I remember this day
like it was yesterday my first my first
year in Philadelphia okay and Erie walks
in in and II was notorious he would
always talk to the guys all day and if
he's a great guy we'll talk to us all
the time as soon as he went to his press
conference he barely said anything is my
fault
it says time G times yours all those
types of things barely said anything but
he came into the team meetings like
listen the media is not your friend
they're not your friend and they can't
help us win and if you think they can
help us when you can walk off the door
right now these guys in the room look to
your left me right these guys can help
us win to me that's Bill Belichick hey
listen do it the right way the media
can't help you win I don't need all the
nonsense I don't need the noise
apparently Bill Belichick even sits down
his team and goes here are the quit like
though
all the press clippings and say here are
the questions you're going to get and
here's how to answer this I not why
wouldn't you well we're gonna find out
well you wouldn't do that if you had
person to me that's a brilliant way to
go about it because what the last thing
you want to want to do Russian is a be
gonna listen and that's the question he
Facebook live inside the Pittsburgh
Steelers Reika room he didn't respect
the coach obviously so we're gonna see
he respects Bill been he has played Bill
Belichick if you're gonna tell me that
you can guarantee anything about
Antonio's actions then I'm gonna say
you're crazier than a B I am NOT crazy
but I look at that team last night and I
go the Patriots look like the best team
in the NFL by the way to remind
everybody
they have according to Vegas the easiest
schedule in the NFL again and if you
watch the Dolphins holy crap
if you watch the Jets their offense to
nothing and then you watch the bills
look like nothing for three quarters
unbelievable were there who I have a
list of guys teams that after watching
Sunday I believe are still the Super
Bowl contenders how many do you have
tell me how many you have and I'll tell
you if I agree with this three four five
I have other than including the Patriots
I have six I have five in a maybe okay
and we're not gonna we're not gonna like
them maybe okay so we both have New
England yes
Baltimore mmm thoughts without on my
list they're not on your [ __ ] list oh
no all right we're gonna talk about them
soon I know you're a psycho what are you
talking about how do you put Baltimore
your little talk I have them winning the
I had them winning the top seed in the
AFC and they're a Super Bowl contender
really we'll get to that in a second
Dallas your list is a shame Dallas is on
the list yeah good Kansas City yes
Philadelphia that's my maybe goodies my
mate okay we'll get to that Minnesota
yes okay that's my six and then I don't
have Rams or Panthers I replace
Baltimore with the Rams okay I think
they get better as it season goes let's
talk Rams really quick that Rams
Panthers game the the fear that I had
going in I obviously told everyone that
I love the Panthers to win this game
yeah and then the Panthers go out there
and DJ more has to
fumbles and Cam Newton looks awful he
had a qbr of 17.1 he missed Kurtis
Samuel - why don't throw emotion again
that definitely looked like he didn't I
think his longest pass was 17 yards yeah
Christian McCaffrey went off had 61
percent of their total yards but my
issue with the Rams was golf goes 186
one touchdown one pick qbr of 20 his
average completion was three point four
yards past the line of scrimmage
last year it was seven so I look at golf
I told you guys he is now 11 touchdowns
- 12 interceptions when he's playing on
the road when he's under pressure he's
not the same guy I know that they were
saving girly and girly really went off
in the fourth quarter but I and when it
all kind of got banged up but Jared Goff
scares me from this team getting back
and they're a maybe let me take that I
the Rams and Panthers are both maybes
for me but I didn't have them in my big
six I'll start with the Panthers and
listen I know cam doesn't want to run
yeah yeah and I remember just like it
was yesterday when Donovan decided he
didn't want to run anymore either
he wanted to be in a pocket passer and
to me you take away a big part of your
game when you're big solid quarterback
doesn't want to run cam had negative 2
yards yesterday to me cam takes that
offense on a different level yes with
the possibility - you're wrong think
about this the when the first touchdowns
the game for the Panthers direct snap to
Christian McCaffrey faked the handoff to
carry and it froze the defense right
because that's the threat that cam can
be they expect him to touch the ball
right around the goal line right right
in the red zone so a I'm not running
that kind of scares me there were some
times where cam looked like the old cam
missing wide open receivers
not timing wasn't there looked like his
oh his mechanics went back to the old
ones but let's talk about the Rams and I
think Jared golf has to figure it out
and this is what happened last year
towards the latter part of the season
defense would played them totally
different they said can you dink and
dunk can you complete the crossers and
not the deep shot can't you be
disciplined enough to take those smaller
gains and work your way down the field
Shaun McVeigh has two
if we all believe that he's this genius
right that we've all said that he is he
has to figure out how to get his
quarterback to say okay we can win this
way right you talk about the group of
receivers they have three very good
receivers two very good running backs
and a quarterback has to figure I think
Charlie ever it's a pretty good tight
end no doubt it but Sean mcvade came out
in the second half yesterday with a few
wrinkles some wide receiver pulling in
jet sweeps that were very creative but
in the end when it's third and six
you need a quarterback to make a play
Kansas City
mahomes looked unbelievable again that's
a good Jacksonville defense the Tyreke L
injury I think is big apparently he
might go on I are designated to return
so he might be out six seven weeks but I
look at Kansas City and Sammy Watkins
and I go oh they're gonna miss that much
of a beat like losing Tyreke L is big
but I think they were prepared to not
have Tyree killed right when they
drafted me Cole Hardman that's right and
so I look at those two and Kelsey and
Williams and shady they have enough
weapons I think to withstand losing
Tyreke wait here's a question and
everybody is saying Patrick mahomes
obviously MVP last year if you're the
MVP you can elevate you can get over one
injury yes if you're that guy and I
think he is that guy I think that when
you bring in shady and you still have
Williams there that you have a running
attack obviously Kelsey is gonna do this
thing there's no doubt about that
as long as he's can stay healthy the big
question still in Kansas City is how
good can this defense be I mean if you
got a win this defense is gonna have to
play all physically I'm not concerned I
think Andy Reid is one of the better
play designer he doesn't get credit
these young guys are getting McVeigh and
I don't really read one of the play
designers by people that know the game
statistically now for the last two years
the Chiefs are the best passing offense
at avoiding tight windows which means
Andy Reed creates space scheming guys
you don't have to throw it in that's
right
Sammy Watkins touchdown yesterday wide
open
Kelsey on the crossing pattern eyes wide
open Andy Reid's ability with time to
scheme it up is unbelievable it's just
can you get over the time management
issues some of those things and this is
the fear with losing Tyree kill
some of those things it's enough it's a
different game it's resolving phillium
DeSean Jackson you have to be afraid of
me : Sammy Watkins Fame too no questions
so that's why it's so important to get
pardon but those guys were open because
of Terry killed and things like that so
yeah I mean defenses have to respect
that and Erie does a great job of making
sure that you find holes he one of the
things he always describes is spacing we
have the space a defense out if we want
a guy in front of the defender and got
behind him if he steps up and takes the
guy in front of him we throw right
behind and we replace him if he goes
back we throw in front of him it's
pretty simple it makes it much easier on
the quarterback all right we're going to
the one that we got the argument we'll
get back to the Eagles Baltimore Ravens
mm-hmm how could you watch any of that
and not go this is a Super Bowl quality
team do you still doubt Lamar Jackson
after he goes 17 to 24 3 24 5 touchdowns
yeah perfect QB rating you still doubt
him I love that he completed his first
team passing because that shows
improvement right away in the biggest
jump usually from your rookie year to
your second year we see a kid that has
improved he was reluctant to run if he
did run at all they had a couple designs
runs in there yeah six yards rushing
which is to me perfect only three runs
that's nice for him the question for me
is doesn't have to do with Lamar Jackson
it doesn't have to do with Mark Ingram
who went over a hundred yards doesn't
have to do any of those receivers it's
all about their competition listen they
play the Dolphins we can't we can't
judge Lamar Jackson against the Dolphins
I mean here's the thing I could have
through some of those passes I'm
summarize our running scott-free down
the middle of the field
the Dolf is absolutely quit before the
dog went for a coin flips so Football
Outsiders they've actually proven over
time that blowout wins are a better
indicator of quality teams then close
wins over good teams because it's so
rare to blow out teams now I'll say this
yeah if we were gonna find one issue
with the Dolphins
it was gonna be their run defense their
defensive line they're switching from a
four three two three four their
linebackers are soft but everyone told
me that the Dolphins secondary was
actually pretty good that it was Minka
Fitzpatrick and Anne's avian Howard's
yeah
best top five quarter in the NFL and
they went out there and destroyed it and
my thing is is when I look at the Ravens
42 points in the first half
Moke at most in week one in NFL history
the biggest difference is I hated
watching the Ravens for the last three
years if you asked me one team hey man
we got five TVs and six games which one
do we leave off optic and the Ravens
because they were the king of dominating
a team for three quarters Flacco's put
up 16 points with three Justin Tucker
field goals and they're not winning him
and the issue was I thought they kept
building teams to get first downs
Michael Crabtree yeah
big receivers big bands lays down open
plays I look around now Hollywood Brown
speed be gone be Willie Sneed could be
gone he'll justice he'll the running
back Boykin the kid out of Boykins the
kid out of Notre Dame Mark Andrews he
might be the fastest tight end in the
NFL B they have built a team with speed
and the reason that I need you to get on
the Ravens as a team right now is of any
team in the NFL which we talked about a
Antonio Brown earlier yeah the only team
that I believe has the secondary to
maybe match up with the Patriots is the
Ravens Brandon Carr Jimmy Smith Marlin
Humphrey Cyrus Jones Earl Thomas is a
baller Tony Hawk versus they got some
dogs in a second they have in my mind
the second best secondary in the NFL
behind the Patriots and so I look at the
Ravens and and I look at what they put
on tape yesterday and we talked on the
phone yesterday on this when when you
see an offense in the Ravens offense
Ingram got his big runs but only six
yards from Lamar Jackson right and all
deep passes yeah how do you game plan
for them right now well because they're
they want to run the ball this is a
classic and I'm talking about classic
overreaction by you classic overreaction
you see you see 59 normally you see this
you see that they got a brand new
offensive coordinator Greg Roman comes
in they don't know the Dolphins have no
clue
what they're gonna run some unscaled it
looks weird to see the Ravens play the
Cardinals this week that's a good
challenge right of course that's a great
challenge no listen this is just what we
know about the Dolphins they were they
were complaining all week long your
trade Tunsil would get some kicks in so
everyone's complaining distraction noise
sure they're looking for a reason to
give up you tell my players want to quit
they want to get trade in two different
teams they're looking for reasons they
don't have any scouting on a kid then
last year ran the ball 25 times a game
and this year Lamar Jackson comes out
throwing the football it's a different
look for them I'm trying to tell you
calm down pump your brakes just a little
bit on the Ravens I listen I like I love
their defense and I think they're
provement for Lamar Jackson is
incredible yes I can't go to the Super
Bowl so I will I will say this to quit
to call my own stuff too last year the
Ravens beat the bills by 44 and week one
they lost to the bit the Bengals the
next week AJ greement off two years ago
they beat the Browns and Bengals 44 to
10 in those first two games combined
week three they go to London lose to the
Jaguars 44 to 7 I get it the difference
is is the Baltimore Ravens those years
came out of nowhere I've been all over
the Ravens for a while the one thing I
will say is is week three they play the
Chiefs we're gonna learn a lot about the
Ravens in that game well there's a
here's the other thought process it's
easy it's convenient it's it's much
easier for a quarterback a team to go
add another team and they're just
retreating this dolfyn seems a and that
they didn't have a chance from the
beginning yes well you have somebody
else coming back at you now you see the
real votes I want to make a bet with you
about the Ravens but I want to think
about it and when I get back on
Wednesday yeah yeah hurry up I mean
think about it quickly because it to me
he's making all over the ring classic
overreaction for the first week don't
overreact on the first week I'm gonna
beat the [ __ ] laughing spent classic
overreaction speaking of the team they
beat imagine you're a Miami Dolphin okay
they trade Laremy Tunsil
it's official you know that your team is
going in the tank and you're sitting
there in a sport where you have two and
a half years average and you know that
one of your years is being wasted
where's weir
what point am I at my career my butt
Ricky just on my 10 year event because
that makes a big difference say you're a
three year vet okay
right in the middle all right you find
out that agents are getting called by
your teammates I need to get the [ __ ]
out of here
yeah and then you sit down on Monday
morning and you go you know what I'm
gonna do what my coach said I'm gonna
put my head down I'm gonna focus I'm
gonna put on this game film of my next
opponent and I'm gonna put it behind me
mm-hmm and you turn on the game film and
it's the [ __ ] Patriots from saying
yeah that sucks
that's holy crap well this is the line
is 15 it might as well be 40 yeah it's
bad down there this is what would that
be like for you well this is what it
would be like we would have a team
meeting and here's the reason why
listen we got we got 15 more games left
and we can't we can't lose by 49 every
doggone game it looks like we could but
we can't do that yes as a team right we
need to have a team meeting nobody's
going anywhere
it's just so you know we know you're not
getting traded you're not getting
released you're not pulling the AP you
gonna have to be here so you better make
the most of it right and if the Patriots
are the next our idea our thought
process has to be let's go let's go beat
the SH underdogs shock the world that
has to be that's the only thing you can
do yeah it's gotta be by 49 my running
quarterback in the back your head I'm
saying we're taking that's what we're
doing of course of course you have to
think that but again we're not it this
usually happens at the end of the season
when you know it's over this yeah now we
have this team weeks late left and you
have a brand-new coach if I'm if I'm
Flores I'm saying I'm coming to my team
like listen and I know some of you guys
called for an office I know you talk to
your agents and I don't really give a
damn
without all I want for you guys is hard
work I want you guys to be disciplined
and I'll figure it out as the head coach
that's what I want Oh give me everything
you have every single day and I'll
figure it out you don't got to worry
about a dog yeah I know which is a hard
sell you should be idea to everybody
talking [ __ ] about you all the time
the thing it - about the Dolphins is I
circled
before the year week - Patriots at
Dolphins as a great time to bet against
the Dolphins
well I mean you had against the Patriot
the patrons always get trouble but the
doll
down there in Miami yeah it's going to
be hot again but the problem is is in my
right mind how the hell do you put
anything on this dolphins team it just
feels like a losing bet but everything
in my gambling mind yeah says Circle it
up well here's a question too bad you
don't whole you know what else it has
its Belichick facing a former assistant
and that's not be lost no it's great
it's great for the Dolphins no
something's not good for bella' he lost
he lost afraid well in the Titans he
lost uh Patricia and the Lions it's like
a gift he gives like Oh Patricia that's
what happened last year let me help ya
the Patriot I took my headphones off the
Patriots like the Lions get shellacked
by the Jets and week one come back and
beat the Patriots at home in week two
you okay but Dan I might go dolphins I
might do it I might put money on it what
do you think that this pair is gonna be
twelve it's 15 right now I mean if I was
vacation in Miami is it in Miami Miami
yeah yeah I'm just telling you the
Dolphins always give them fits brand new
coat huh big time question marks with
with the quarterback situation I mean I
think there's question marks across that
across the board so um I actually just
found out that these players have been
reaching out to their agents our
esteemed producer David came across a
voicemail he has sources David's
becoming an NFL insider yeah of what one
of the voicemails were that's here I'm
an unnamed Dolphins player to an agent
so we don't know which Dolphins player
it is but it is so let's take a listen
and see how bad it really is in Miami
hey Ryan
today was a rough one we lost our
football game by like 200 points I kind
of stopped counting midway through the
second quarter and let me tell you
something it was not fun and it's weird
because like back in college blowouts
were awesome
UCLA would beat the ever-loving crap out
of UNLV and we'd have a big party on
campus and it was awesome but yesterday
it was different it was it was not fun
and I don't really know what the
difference is but I kind of don't want
that feeling again so yeah this is all
just a long way of me saying I want
I'm happy to go be a backup for Aaron
Rodgers or patrocle Holmes or Russell
Wilson but I'm also totally down to
convert to wide receiver and win a Super
Bowl ring with the Patriots mmm
sincerely anonymous young Dolphins
quarterback definitely not Josh Rosen
must I don't know who that was I can't
tell who it was it sounds like jr. I'll
just fake jr. sounds like sounds like
jr. Michael I'm not saying any names
think about this Josh Rosen was the
seventh pick in the draft yeah the
Cardinals traded up to get him he goes
to a franchise where not only do they
not feel confident to build around him
they fire his head coach after a season
draft a quarterback instead and then
trade him to this team yeah he's sitting
there on the sidelines on a team that is
now tanking completely given away all of
their chances to win and playing behind
Ryan Fitzpatrick who's everybody's best
friend and he looks across the field at
Lamar Jackson who went 32nd in the same
draft and to a Baltimore Ravens team
that said you know what we're gonna get
rid of our Flacco quarterback Joe Flacco
won us a Super Bowl and we're gonna
change the identity of our entire team
to build around you we're gonna get new
weapons we're gonna enforce our
offensive line we're gonna bring in an
offensive coordinator that has
experiences with Tyrod Taylor and Colin
Kaepernick and build the offense around
you and Josh Rosen has to be sitting
over there going how the [ __ ] did I get
dealt these cards I mean he's looking
over at a team that built around a
quarterback and he's on his second team
that's looking at him going not only do
we not think you're the guy we're gonna
we're gonna roll the dice and hope that
we get the chance to draft somebody that
might not be the guy either that's the
part that - why would you trade form it
if you already know that you're gonna
jazz somebody else later on I think you
I understood it because you go maybe we
bring him in here and an Arizona
offensive line was so bad right let's
see him in training camp it's probably
part of the reason why Antonio Brown
wanted out of Oakland he saw Derek Carr
throw in passes and went
yeah I bet you the Dolphins they brought
in Josh Rosen they went because the true
thing is is if it's a battle between
Josh rose and Ryan Fitzpatrick he ain't
the quarterback of the future if your
quarterback never had been a battle with
Ryan Fitzpatrick he's not the guy
yeah it's listen when you look at this
team I mean you have to wonder what's
going on down there and you listen you
give up your left tackle and you don't
tank I mean listen if you're a head
coach if your floor is do you say we're
tanking you can't say that you can't
even say that in football at all
we both know Philly Bret Braun was
rewarded for two or three years for
Sixers right for going out there and
teams would go tell you what that team
they don't got any Talent they've played
[ __ ] hard hard and that's Brian
Flores the problem is is as a player how
can you continue to be told just do this
and then you see no rewards I'll tell
you this I'm in San Francisco my last
season in the NFL and we had a talented
team two years later they're in the
doggone Super Bowl by the way with with
with Harbaugh similar team and every
week we're open six we were bad
Singletary so you were on the Niners
yeah Niners yeah I forgot these syncro
Terry comes in every week and says
listen guys you don't understand we're
this close
we're this close and I'm in my mind like
I'm not playing a bunch Frankie's taking
all that carries and I might I'm sitting
there like no no no we're not we're not
disclose because we're but we're this
far away from super bitter bitter good
teams no discipline it was just all bad
right and so the coach is gonna have to
come in to lie to these guys I mean
there's no doubt about it
he can't come in and sugarcoat this no
you can't come in the only way you could
come in and say you say hey we look
terrible yesterday we're not gonna watch
the film you don't want you don't watch
this film because it's all bad I have
nothing good to say about you guys on
this film do you don't want so you've
extended a tradition on this podcast
which is
players coming on and revealing that
Mike Singletary was the worst head coach
in the history of football he says not
your words as his mind yeah but I'm
going to say that I've had four people
really tell stories about Mike
Singletary and being like Johnny
football and the rest of the team
looking and go
and this isn't working right I know of
me I'll tell you this he's a great guy
great guy great guy he gives the best
motivational speeches I just think that
it wasn't his right time to be a coach
he wasn't really quite Sean Payton's the
kind of guy that has gotten the
perfected down of the the motivation
pulls the fire alarm yeah you know what
I mean and says we got to be ready for
anything right
brings out money rangos this is why we
need to win cuz we need to get a hundred
thousand dollars the coach for a little
bit is a little bit like a substitute
teacher you got a class that is really
trying to get focused another [ __ ] right
and you need to find creative ways to
get them back there and Bill Belichick
will [ __ ] on Brady and everyone hears
about it and that gets everybody focused
but if you go there every week and go we
gotta tough it out
we need to focus on our assignment work
that way but if you go there and go
we're gonna live in the Dolphins we're
gonna end Brady we're gonna get six acts
on Brady
and maybe you get that one statistical
category and maybe you get the
confidence but you need to find those
little wind well this is what he says
then in that in that same vein I know
how to beat this team number tell you
how we're gonna matter [ __ ] it is what
you say I know how to beat this team you
attacked Tom Brady in every single play
we're gonna blitz him we're gonna play
you know man-to-man on the back side
we're gonna blitz him make him move the
pocket and see if he can beat us yeah
that's what you say all right so you
were at the Eagles Washington game on
Sunday yeah and you're sitting there
with a bunch of former players too and
they go down 17 to nothing mm-hmm were
you nervous no no no listen to me I was
nervous
and here's why no preseason for Carson
yep you're saying all the old guys all
the guys that play with me David Akers
and I crease and Freddie Mitchell all
the old guys including myself we're all
sassy and he knows how the way to do it
you know the old-school way to do it you
know you go you hit someone in the mouth
all preseason right you get ready for
the first game of you're ready all right
so you guys were sitting on duck weed us
with the old guys do with the game right
coach's birth dear
we used to do it this way and you know
that's what old guys doing so we're
saying listen this looks bad because
Washington wasn't stopping I mean guys
are running scot-free down the middle of
the field
it wasn't Terry our deviance character
it came out of nowhere
so the defense looks terrible
offensively you couldn't do anything
Carson with this wasn't on his game we
couldn't run the ball
we weren't moved with things and this is
a team listen the points where it was
ten in half we wasn't blowing this team
out the Eagles have traditionally
started slow first quarter had looked
terrible in the first quarter but
finally they turned it around just a bit
and it looked good so words in but a am
I happy this is why I have the Eagles as
a question mark footed superb yeah let's
hear because I have them as not a
question mark really you have them
solidly a descender well here's the
reason why
I you need great quarterback play
I think Carson looked good that second
half he did some things flipping the
hits get getting outside the pocket
rolled into the right rolled into the
left squaring up throwing the ball down
the field
he made one throw to DeSean Jackson the
ball is on the left hash DeSean is on
the right side of the field
he runs a 12 yard out yeah probably the
longest or you could throw in football
but beside a bomb a Hail Mary whatever
cuz he threw two of those teen it was a
strike me told my heat through the ball
it was a beauty arm talent what was it
like to watch your guy
DeSean Jackson come back to Philly and
about 150 two touchdowns and two bombs
that were not just like good bombs they
were necessary what was that like for
you as a former team well it's crazy
because you always think about yourself
in that position and I'm saying well if
I was in that position I don't know how
I would feel coming back to Philly
yeah after being kicked out basically I
because our Chip Kelly fake-ass guys
gang ties supposedly in now you play
your old team that you got kicked out to
right and now I want to go out and show
up against my old team but I really want
to remind the people in Philly
yes what I'm all about in there were two
other balls he couldn't complete it
could have completed two DeSean Jackson
down the middle of the 3d Jack still at
32 is the fastest guy on the field
I mean he's streaking pass
Josh Norman right past us on slow motion
I mean he can't move if it day the old
adage if your even your beat he's gone
yeah and he's deathless if your even
your leave is that what it is he
believed but the point is yeah you know
the old saying knock-knock who's at my
door you know what I mean but it was
good to see Dee Jack back it was good to
see the presence that he had in the
office but talk about putting something
on tape putting something on tape here's
three three teams we saw it in the first
game of the season Green Bay the game
didn't open up Green Bay looked terrible
until the deep ball until Martel Valdez
yeah yeah and Martez bobbed again so he
hits the ball deep then it opens up
everything yes because the defenses have
to be aware then you can hit the
underneath stuff we talked about it with
Tyreke kill same thing with the Ravens
yeah same thing
go deep I'm gonna throw it as far as I
can Hollywood Brown how do we brown down
the middle of the field same thing with
with Carson Wentz DeSean Jackson I just
put that on tape it's just hard to go to
Torrey Smith when they won the Super
Bowl Torrey Smith had about maybe a
dozen of those catches yes and they came
into last year and said our replacement
for Torrey Smith is Mike wise and people
like me were going mike wallace has not
played like four games in a year like
ever welcome Mike Wallace catch that was
all you might was the other question
catch now you get to Sean Jackson now
the next few weeks teams are gonna drop
back and they're gonna go kind of be
worried about Sean they're looking for
DeSean yeah and now it's
Earths we can't afford to get beat by DJ
it's al shot it opens it up but when I
saw it off Carson when he was the MVP
before he got hurt that year and got
robbed he had one of the greatest the
statistical seasons as a quarterback on
third down he was converting third and
long at a historic rate right you know
he did on third long a third down
yesterday 12 of 13 197 yards three
touchdowns and a 150 8.3 aka
a perfect quarterback rating carson
wentz on third down has been the key to
his success and the
Eagles and for him to do that yesterday
with their back against the wall down 17
nothing that's why for me they're not a
question mark but the reason I am scared
is looks like Malik Jackson might be
going on IR yep that hurts your D line I
have a lot of fears about this team
if Case Keenum hits Thierry Mugler
Michaela Maclaurin on that deep pass in
the third quarter yeah
we're in an absolute race we had just
score so it was 2120 at that point yes
so we had scored 21 unanswered yeah or
something like that or 21 to 3 if he
competes completes that different game
it's a different game different game and
I have a lot of concerns about this
secondary because I think that there are
3 sixes and not a lot of tens and I have
a lot of concerns now about this pass
rush if Malik Jackson's out and Timmy
Jernigan is in there
I love Timmy journey but what I don't
have a lot of faith in is Derek Barnett
I don't have a lot of faith in Josh
sweat I don't have a lot of faith in all
of these guys getting pressure because
Case Keenum was not under pressure
yesterday well that was with Malik
Jackson for most of the say that was
whip I my biggest concern about the
Eagles has always been the defensive end
position you lose you lose
you know double-digit sacks we lose
Michael Bennett and Chris long yeah
veteran leadership listen probably not
mine those guys always came up in the
clutch came up huge Michael Clannad and
Chris long in the clutch was everything
and I didn't see it yesterday
nope we didn't see that and then the
cornerbacks yes Rasul Douglas is getting
blown by like as if he wasn't even
seeing what was going on and so that
makes did the same way we're talking
about on offense that makes Jim Swartz
change his defense now to me I always
wanted Jim Swartz to blitz more
yesterday they go cover 0 I showed you
the clip they go covers hero now Joe
Sarno a real body in the middle in the
field
yeah Rasul Douglas gets beat straight
down the field these are going to be
playing Case Keenum and that Y receiving
core it could have been interesting and
they play the Falcons this week and
they're going to be hungry and the
pouches will be hungry in their house
they just lose their starting right
tackle for about eight weeks with a bro
foot Linstrom your confidence meter that
the Eagles will go to the Super Bowl I
want to do this every week yeah one
through ten right now right now right
now and I like to start in a reasonable
mind because I'm not a I don't overreact
like you you're over reactionist is that
we're over reactionist it is now today
it is I'm starting out of five and in
here's why a slow start can be trouble
against team that can continue to score
the Redskins could if they could have
continued just kick field goals we're in
trouble
it gets teams that can continue to score
which I think the Minnesota Vikings can
be right the Dallas Cowboys can be
there's some other teams that I think
ins can continue to score we talked
about Seattle they can continue to score
let by good quarterbacks that's the
trouble mark for the Eagles I'm still
worried about the defense when they won
the Super Bowl
they had edge pressure yes and I'm
concerned about that and a cornerback
that can play I'm not sure that they had
I am gonna put that I'm gonna put my
confidence meter at a 6.4 I look at the
Eagles I think they have all the pieces
huh
but I look at a few of the other teams
Dallas yeah what Minnesota did and I
look at the weaknesses of the Eagles
that I'm at a 6.4 I'm gonna tell you
what can we can raise this I'm wary
about a five we can raise it is Carson
Wentz coming out this game playing a
full four quarters of good football
quarterback playing can take you over to
edge either way that can go up to eight
eight point one eight point two just
like that with Carson Wentz playing for
good quarters football I would say 90%
of my rating is because their offense
mile Sanders showed me some spark
yesterday I like it i al Sean and DeSean
is exactly what we hoped got hurt and
it's solid the offensive line was moving
people was a nice offensive line Jason
Peter I don't I don't listen I'm 30 I'm
from 40 now he's 37 I don't know how
he's playing football cuz last year he
looked like this was his last time
walking just walking in and in blocking
at the same time this year yesterday
yeah I was impressed by Jason Peters but
all of my fears for the Eagles are
defensive right now I believe that the
worst coordinator is the defensive
coordinator of the
I have more faith in Peterson Colin
place than I do Jim Schwartz I have a
lot of fears about the defensive ends
their linebackers are hurt they'll get
grew J Hill back in a later time and the
secondary is a whole lot of average it's
it's funny that you said that Jim
Schwartz is the worst defense aquinnah I
had a guy tell me yesterday that Jim
Swartz he has earned himself our head
coaching job well you need to get better
for for the job that he's done with the
average players that he had in the
secondary okay that's what he told me
and I would say that you can have
average players in the secondary when
you have Fletcher Cox Michael Bennett
Chris long Timmy Jernigan like all those
guys get after the quarterback I think
Jim Schwartz a good coach decent I'm not
I'm saying that he's a worse coordinator
than Doug Peterson as an offensive
coordinator when the thing he's done has
wanted to top five or six coordinators
that's what I'm saying so I'm not saying
that now sheemish warts as bad I'm just
saying these worse okay
Dallas Cowboys because that's the team
right now that you come away from that
game and going holy crap let me put some
stuff into perspective
Dax numbers 25 a 32 404 four touchdowns
150 8.3 the Cowboys scored touchdowns on
five straight possessions yesterday
first time that's happened in Dallas in
19 years Kellen Moore is the new OC last
year it was hilariously predictable that
they would be running on either first
and ten or second and ten right the
Cowboys came out yesterday and 21 of
their 33 plays on first or second down
were passes that would have matched the
Chiefs rating from last year the Cowboys
so they threw in about 60% of pay on
first and second down last year they
threw on just 51 percent which was 11th
worst I look at what Kellen Moore has
done and that offense
Michael gallop Randall Cobb the blade
char when Jason Witten looks serviceable
Zeke this offense looked completely
different it looked like it was hitting
a lot of different levels concepts more
importantly doc was accurate at every
level good touch across the middle
amazing touch deep this offense looks
for real it did not look like a flash in
the pan a couple things that we saw from
the offense it's not predictable they're
using motion pre-snap holy-shit motion
in Dallas who would have ever thought
nobody was thought about it they're
using a lot of play-action which
obviously they've done that before but
it'll be different now the play-action
before was was guys crossing the field
yes that guy's in the middle of the
field yesterday we saw guys in the
middle of the field now this is what I
saw from dak and in you talk about a guy
gambling betting on himself this is how
you get over 30 million bucks man
you play stuff 40 well well I tell you
you can you play the Giants which that
helps but he knows the Giants he looked
poised in a pocket he understood it
looks like the game they always talk
about the game slowing down so you
understand what the defense is doing
before they actually do it yeah I
understand that hey this is a cover -
these guys are gonna be here these other
guys is gonna be here I know where I
need to get the ball in the middle of
the field I know that it feels like the
games have slowed him down for dak he
has great poise in the pocket
he's so great arm strip and accuracy
yeah if you could get that type of play
from dag and you get a little bit more
get a little bit more 421 yeah oh let
him guess it's just it's just hard so
it's hard to beat that
you add to that it last year I thought
Michael Gallup was gonna hang out year
we saw the speed in the preseason him at
dak had a great connection in the
preseason during the season it just
didn't really materials are cuz Amari
wasn't there and no Cal it wasn't ready
to be a number one he wasn't ready and
you know you did your hand in the ball
all 25 times now he's a threat you told
me open up the middle of the field we
talked about opening up things this is
exactly what you want
Amari Cooper will continue to come in
six cases 106 yards easy day at the
office for him this office looks the
exact way that it should
we're talking about they have a great
run game if they wanted to go third and
to run they have the offensive line in
the personnel to do it if they want to
go third and 10 and get up completion
down the field they have the right arm
talent quarterback wise to be able to do
it he's thinking the game he understands
it and I think bringing in kind of more
John kitten is a quarterback coach two
guys have played the position yeah they
made acting differently about the
position quarterback offensive
coordinators that have played the
position know how to design plays at the
quarterback once to the throw that's
right and dak every play looked like it
was right and Dax wheelhouse this is
what's scary if you're not a Cowboys fan
if you're a Cowboys fan you gotta be
thrilled
Byron Jones was coming off of hip injury
and didn't play the whole game no
DeMarcus Lawrence was coming off
shoulder surgery and didn't play the
whole game Amari Cooper was supposed to
have a foot injury Zack Martin has been
battling a disk injury in his back and
only had to play half the game Zeke was
in Cabo and was rusty and dak isn't a
new offense and they just shall act the
Giants if there was a time where you
were supposed to get the Cowboys week it
was week one and they looked better than
they have in Dax entire career and I
meant to say this foredeck is there any
better time to negotiate a conscious
yeah we're the Doodlebops
yeah and you come out there with a
perfect quarterback rating and a hundred
and fifty eight point three and he sits
out there at the press conference and he
goes we'll get to my contract that's
right and Jerry goes it's imminent yeah
if your boss is going hey you know dak
we're gonna get the deal done the next
few days you're going that's right no no
not only do I got all the leverage no no
let me play a couple more games let me
keep showing you because that was that
was Thursday playing Washington this
yeah I'd like to do it again guess what
I play why oh that's 3435 he just keeps
going up yes that's exactly what you
want and he bet on himself and this is a
perfect opportunity because kind of more
has been with him all offseason right
right
dak big Zeke hasn't been there ZK so
Kelly Morris like listen let's go
wind-up throw the glenda game throwing
the football yes all quarterbacks I
remember where Doug was here and he was
there in Philadelphia with me when I was
- yeah he was an assistant in all former
quarterbacks or the only way that they
understand how to win games and get out
of trouble is throwing the football
hmm that's great for dad graver there
that's right in his wheelhouse
this is exactly how he gets his money
carrying this football team NFL media
has made the switch and it's typically
newer younger people that have realized
I mean there is a website and I love
Evan Silva and Adam Levitin
called establish the run mm-hmm it's
called establish the run to make fun of
people that believe that you need to
establish the runs right because we're
the NFL now is you establish the pass
and that opens up the run
we always joke oh if this team has 25
carries they win 95% of the time well
then just start off at 25 carries that's
not the reason is that typically the
reason that you win with that many runs
is because you're ahead and then you run
we all believe that the Dallas Cowboys
are going to run you don't need to run
in the beginning of the game to set up
the play-action we already think you are
so use the play-action to set up the run
later the one thing I will say about
this team is Randall Cobb I do not
believe is gonna be like this every week
I went back and looked he hasn't played
16 games in three years also last year
week one 37% of his yards for the season
happened in week one two years ago the
most catches out of any game that year
was in week one Randall Cobb is like a
week one legend member his rookie year
took a kick return for a touchdown
Reno Cobb always bump in week one he has
a lot of injuries that kind of like
lowered over the years well this is what
I think about Randall Cobb and this is
why I think he has a little bit higher
ceiling than what you're thinking sure
this offense you're gonna run a ball a
bunch in his offense they didn't do that
in Green Bay so he was he was running
way they gave me the third down months
in he's a third guy here gallops no
order to yeah they're gonna get the ball
he only needs four or five catches per
game get yourself 40 to 80 yards per
game I think he can do that I just want
to say one more thing because dak is
probably gonna need a contract when this
podcast comes out he's like he said call
us and thank 130 million no I want to
have a talk with Jerry Jones yeah
because Jerry Jones tried to be the
master negotiator art of the deal too on
Jerry Jones
what does Jerry Jones done this
offseason he gave to Marcus Lawrence the
highest contract for any defensive end
he gave Zeke the highest contract for
any running back after saying Zi ku and
trying to do an onslaught of media he
comes out before Sunday's game and
somehow there's a contract
there's did you know that dak is getting
fifty million dollars in all field
endorsements so maybe he doesn't need it
yeah that story came out Sunday morning
Jerry Jones tried to be the master
negotiator all offseason and all he's
done is give out the biggest contract at
every single position and let dak go out
there and have a perfect quarterback
rating and then do the deal some of the
worst negotiating because he's the king
of the double talk one day he saying
he's the best thing smoking all we love
this guy we want him to do everything
and then the next day he said we don't
want to Pam maybe listen you can't
believe both if you believe in them
you're gonna have to pay him especially
at that position you're gonna have to
pay him in especially if you're saying
you don't want to pay the other guy
which he ended up doing ended up paying
Zeke he's thinking you're gonna have to
pay to quarterback but now if I'm Byron
Jones or Amari Cooper and they're the
next two up hey we don't have enough
money I think you might I'll wait I'll
wait you might you always cave look and
this is a thing Cowboys have one of the
easiest pass defense schedules or
playing this year their next two games
Washington Miami tax gonna keep it to
ching-ching let me ask you this if
you're dak do you wait to after Miami or
do you say yeah well you know what's the
number now I wait and see than um you
wait yeah I 140 140 a year yeah let's
figure it out they were the team that we
are going okay we have this new
offensive coordinator we have a
quarterback that's kind of up-and-coming
we'll see how they do and they exceeded
expectations there were no more
expectations on any team the NFL than
the Cleveland Browns and there was no
performance on Sunday other than maybe
the Steelers and the Dolphins as
disappointing as the Cleveland Browns
they lose by 30 in a home opener in a
year in which you're saying you're a
Super Bowl contender 18 penalties in
week 1 the most in 68 years for the
Browns 180
two yards they had six penalties in the
15-yard variety one was because of a
punch on miles Garrett one was because
of a kick on Greg Robinson who got
kicked out of the game little kick to
roughing the passer their offensive line
is so bad they let Greg Robinson go he
cleared waivers and they brought him on
their offensive line is so bad that when
he got kicked out and then they're back
up Kendall Lam got a knee injury they
moved their starting right tackle Chris
Hubbard to the left tackle and had to
play Justin McCray at right tackle who
had just signed with the Browns the
Monday before their offensive line is so
bad that when they were trying to kick a
field goal in the third quarter their
defensive tackle Larry egg and Joby had
to play offensive line and this is what
my season-long predictions were it's the
reason I did not have the Browns making
the playoffs you can have Jarvis Landry
and you can have O'Dell and you can even
joke ooh and you can have chub but if
your offensive line is a mess and you
traded your best offensive lineman Kevin
Zeidler to the Giants I don't care who
your weapons are if your offensive line
isn't good it doesn't matter Baker
Mayfield got hit so hard that I think
there might be something wrong with his
throwing motion because he threw three
picks yeah in the second half after that
I'm in full panic mode on the Browns
right he had a rap on his hand after the
game Eddy when I look at this team to
your point Andy Reed always told us you
win in the trenches offensive defensive
line it you kind of put it in
perspective for a house that's like up
in your bedroom on the fourth floor you
got to you know the TV on the wall you
got the stereo system got the jacuzzi
and everything in it but it's held up by
toothpicks on the bottom you have no
foundation
none everybody has to have a foundation
and it starts on the offense line but
even before that here was the two things
I was worried about this football team
when you start winning you start getting
the big head and you're saying hey we're
better than everybody else
you win three four in a row we're better
than everything about he else and if you
lose one you lose two you lose three
this team is it built is it built too
cover from those things is there a
culture is there character on this team
they got a brand new head coach Fredi
kitchen does not coach anywhere know who
was the leader on this team is it Baker
I think it's Baker yeah okay he hasn't
won in the NFL he hasn't shown maturity
to lead a football team of grown men oh
look at this look at the leaders in our
NFL Tom's a leader
drew Brees a leader I think in some ways
Aaron Rodgers is kind of a leader in
some ways but they know how to lead
grown men Patti mahomes seems like a
leader is he is they know how to get
things the best out of other grown men
I'm watching the Arizona game and I'm
going man
there's Terrell Suggs two [ __ ] sacks
doing what he needs to do hey just doing
enough and you hold it on old school
doing it I don't know that the Browns
are built that way I don't know they're
built with enough character and culture
to say listen when things go wrong
things are getting bad we're down by 10
you know we looked at we're close we did
wear it listen it's 1513 that's the end
of the third quarter we're pretty
doggone close now we got to go on a run
we battled back yes who was gonna say
that who's gonna who's gonna say listen
this is what we work for every single
down every single day in practice this
is what we're built on his Baker
Mayfield that guy what do you think I
don't think so
he hasn't shown it yet I am I am he
hasn't shown it yet I I will buy your
stock in the Browns because I think the
Browns are like a nine and seven team I
don't think they're gonna be a under 500
team do they dig that can't be the
Ravens we know that I owe now you're on
the Ravens this great have a really good
defense so I'll say this about the
Browns I am not gonna count out Baker
yet because he's a guy that's been
Canada his whole life and I do believe
he has a leadership gene I believe that
the question though is on Freddie
kitchens Freddie kitchens last year was
able to build an offense when he took
over in the second half that was a lot
of pulling guards a lot of inventive
play calling yeah a lot of Jarvis Landry
runs a Nick Chubb and that's the reason
trading Kevin Zeidler for Olivier Vernon
was unnecessary for me I already like
the Browns d-line but now Freddie
kitchens has to go in the lab and go I
can't do seven step drops I can't do
long developing place also I need to
find a way to get Nick Chubb more
involved to give Baker a little bit of
time every time I looked up yesterday
Baker Mayfield was either running for
his life or on his back
Cameron Wake the ageless wonder for the
Tennessee Titans my eyes had like two
two and a half sacks yesterday the
Tennessee Titans have won a phenomenal
defensive coordinator Dean Pease
longtime Baltimore Ravens defensive
coordinators been there for a few years
that man knows Freddie kitchens yeah he
shut down Freddie kitchens when he was
with the Ravens before but I look at at
the the Titans and I go amazing play
calling that screen to Derek Henry yeah
75 yards down we haven't seen that at
all
I look at the place to AJ Brown who
looks like a [ __ ] monster oh man out
there grown [ __ ] man those DBS are
making business decisions yeah it's not
wanting to tackle him 30 yards down
Laney Walker looked happy to be back
with me in San Fran but I look at the
Titans and I go they're a good team
right now I don't know if they're gonna
sustain that but I look at the Browns
and I go Freddie it's all on you man
you're gonna need to find a way to
reinvent this offense on the fly to
overcome not a lot of time and this is
what you see with the Titans you see a
hard nose a hard coach of fighting
football team they don't have the most
talent in the world they have some good
players they have some quality guys here
and there but they're gonna fight period
and that comes from their head coach
Mike Brown's from frame because he's
nasty I played against Raheen Pease look
and look I think if the tight if the
Patriots have the number one secondary
in the NFL and the Ravens have two you
can make an argument that the Titans
have three we have three starting
quality corners in Butler Ryan and then
the guy I'm dory Jackson you have Kevin
by yard that is one of the best safeties
in the NFL and and I think they have a
lot of really good pieces but the story
is definitely the Browns disappointment
but I'm proud of the Titans but I'm
gonna tell you this and this is true
you've heard this saying before it's a
big difference between being the hunter
and the hunted
you heard what Delanie Walker said oh
they're getting all the credit everybody
crown them all these are who they quoted
did you know why because all baby here
in all offseason is the Browns this the
Browns that they're right by had Kevin
buyer on this podcast in Atlanta mm-hmm
and I said Oh week one man you're
playing Odell and he's like we got
something for ya and that was three
months ago look in their chops I also
tell you this Vegas has been betting the
titans all offseason they they the one
of the number one teams for the Sharps
Vegas was rooting for Tennessee they're
like we'd rather lose to all the very
experienced betters instead of because
all the money was coming in on Cleveland
they're the hyped up right right
everybody was betting anytime it's a big
difference between to hunt it in being a
hunter we talked about really should
think about that for the Eagles the
underdog mentality you can't live that
anymore that they lived on that two
years ago but you're gonna get every
team's best they better get used to that
the Cleveland Browns they better get
because those guys know these highlights
are gonna be on sports absolutely and if
Baker is doing great and he's doing his
little drum thing before the game or
Odell's dancing on all you heard all
season all offseason is that the
Cleveland Browns are the best team in
football best team at AFC really so be
come show me Sports Illustrated show me
I hear that on paper show me yeah what
happens and this is one of the thing
everybody has a game plan to get hit in
the mouth I'm gonna hit you in the mouth
and then I'm gonna see what you're gonna
do so I see how you react that you don't
you not all might say about the Ravens
being the Super Bowl team but I did pick
them to win the AFC North do I like they
look pretty good
after what we saw this jazz last night
it looked like they're the best team in
the AFC North right now yeah saying nice
job I will no I'm not giving any pretty
good I would like to see I would like to
see them I guess a decent football team
that not did that didn't give up before
the game okay can I reserve judgment
it's at that point course because I
would I'm not just remember that they
almost beat the Chiefs in Kansas City
last year if Patrick mahomes doesn't
roll out on fourth and 15 and throw up a
miracle moon shot yeah entire recount
and they cover the spread and I made 100
I almost hit the lottery last year just
so you know a lot of things almost
happen and they that just doesn't work
that way um let's talk about some of the
big injuries
your guy my guy Nick Foles yeah broken
clavicle gonna go on IR designated to
return talk about like it's not as much
as the Dolphins where they feel like
their season's over
obviously with gardner minshew he came
in and played pretty well do you play
well but if you're the Jags and your
defense that you're going we're gonna
shut down the Chiefs week one you let up
a psyche a 30 spot or whatever it was
and you lose your starting quarterback
on a touchdown throw yeah I mean [ __ ]
you got to be feeling like your seasons
like man there goes our year you have to
be feeling that any any team not just
the Jags any team that loses their
starting quarterback and don't forget
how they got Nick flow they were begging
for a quarterback they think the only
thing that they thought last year that
they were missing and last year probably
not a good example because they felt a
part towards the end of the year but
there was a couple years ago when they
they were right there and they needed a
quarterback they needed a quarterback
that could throw the ball make those
tight and small windows make those types
of throws get the office down the field
huh turn the ball over now turn the ball
over so that we're not handing the ball
off to fournette 50 times again that's
what the past game we're talking about
time up the Dallas Cowboys that's what
they were looking for from Nick Foles
unfortunately and I love Nick Foles
great do it made great dude obviously
you always hate to see injury but this
Jack's team they're in trouble because
you have to score points now and I'm not
sure that they can score enough points
defensively they can stop some guys I
love that we're disagreeing this much I
need to write down all of our
disagreements yes you know how many
times you're gonna be wrong well the
only reason that I'm a little bit higher
on Gardner Minshew mmm-hmm is every time
I watched the Jags in pre-season he got
all the [ __ ] snaps because they
didn't play Nick Foles at all and I kept
going who is this guy and I would go to
the depth chart I go always that rookie
at a Washington State and he kept making
plays where I was like so really good
throw it's a really good decision but
you know when you're watching like a
late round pick and the back of your
head even when they do something well
you're like it's the [ __ ] preseason
I'm not counting this all I know is he's
got a connection with DJ shark he's got
a connection with Dede Westbrook the
issue that I have for the Jaguars is
that they had to backup tackles playing
yesterday or JaJuan Taylor rookie
but I don't know who's winning the AFC
South Colts comeback fall short believe
me you don't know who's gonna win it
who do you think the Texans are gonna
win it I'll take that bet - what I did
in Texas like I I think the Texans are
gonna have a much worse here but I think
that Texans are gonna be every single
game for the Texas this year Westbrook
is gonna be 35 to 32 you guys their
defense stinks
yeah now their offense could being the
crowd or some points yeah but they could
finally protect Watson yeah they get
yourself to the left tackle you got a
nice little running back situation there
you got some of the best receivers speed
down the field I mean what else do you
what all offensively I have want a
defense that's not gonna line up 40
points again the Kansas Kansas City gave
up a bunch of points my issue with the
Texans this I think bill O'Brien's on
the worse situational game coaches
that's a whole different thing and so in
the end like I look at the Titans who
just beat the Browns I don't believe in
them long term but I go for Abel peas
and then this guy Arthur Smith who was
the offensive coordinator who's today I
like - he was doing so I like the
coaching they're Texans Bill O'Brien
Romeo Crennel not the biggest fan not a
big fan of Bill O'Brien I acts of 'old
Doug Marrone and uh and it was a Todd
wash or something like that
yeah okay and then the other team that
division is Colts which is Frank Hartman
right Frank right and Matt Eber flus I
like those coaches so and I just see the
Texans dropping some easy [ __ ] games
this year there were some times ladies
I'm talking about the Jags now there
were some times where I thought that
defense that was nasty that just gave up
I and not only the deeper 13 yeah just
gave up I think what I don't like that
one of them yesterday they had a big
time third down with Patrick Mahoney
they get the stop they get a late hit
called and they the team freaks out one
of I think it was DeMarcus Robinson
pushes miles Jack miles Jack punches him
in the face kicked out yeah
miles jack is the heartbeat of that
Jaguars defense he got so emotional that
I think it threw off the Jags and in the
the the Chiefs went out there and
Patrick mahomes had 300 yards passing I
think that I'm gonna try and take
advantage
in my bedding mind of the Jaguars coming
up because I think people are gonna go
oh minshew and that defense yeah mahomes
got [ __ ] nailed a lot yesterday
they've got a lot of pressure on him I'm
gonna tell you what happens with young
quarterbacks interceptions yep
they turn the ball over sacs and fumbles
if you want to make a good defense bad
do that and see how much dick time they
spend on the field oh yeah the defense
minister t5 40 minutes on the field you
see how bad they are
Jacksonville lashes exactly what
happened I think Gardner Minshew is
already better than blank board who did
it have next week let me see what their
schedule is like the jaguars play i
think it's somebody winnable really
let's say they have next week
the texans perfect perfect perfect I put
a wager on that perfect we'll see how
the text is to Monday Night Football
we'll see how they do yeah you know well
no I want to see how the Texans look
against the Saints they're gonna beat
the Saints and they're gonna come back
and lose to the jaguars feel it Todd
Gurley from watching Todd Gurley eight
carries everyone's going oh what's the
deal Malcolm Brown gets the two carries
and in the goal line what was
interesting though was fourth quarter
Todd Gurley got eight carries for 64 for
the gaming went 14 and 97 when the Rams
needed him he went off yeah and I'm not
that worried about Gurley I think that
we are overreacting a little bit because
it's upsetting fantasy owners what do
you mean Oh whose what you mean I think
because they're saying Malcolm Brown is
getting so many carries people are going
something's wrong with Curly's knee yes
mysterious very early is an issue
absolutely at the same point when push
came to shove yesterday they gave Gurley
the rock and Gurley busted off like two
or three runs that were over 10 yards
and I think that they're managing his
carries they're doing what they should
but I think us as fans want girl they'd
get 30 carries there is something wrong
with his knee it is not gonna get better
but they're doing the absolute right
thing yeah it's the first game in a
season
given 14 care
yeah to me his idea range at this point
is 13 to 17 carries because you have
Malcolm Brown you have the Jared golf
hopefully he threw heat throws for a
better game he passes for in a better
game in the future that's what you posed
to do because again for this team we're
not talking about trying to make it to
the playoffs we're talking about we need
this horse Todd Gurley in the backfield
during the playoffs we didn't have them
last year and many people point to that
as a reason why they lost the Super Bowl
to me it's all about preserving him join
just enough to give him the reps win
some football games and make sure that
he's there at the end of the season this
is brilliant by Xiaomi hey listen my
fantasy has ruined people's thoughts
about things it has but this is the
right way to do it and there are people
walking around now going this John Ross
when the best wide receivers in the NFL
calm down for one week so we were
talking about the Browns and their
struggles earlier they play on Monday
night next week the Jets and talk about
two teams that came out and just blew
week one mm-hmm
jets were up what 15 and nothing lost
that game 16 to 15 I got three names
phrases want to talk about Adam GaSe
Adam GaSe comes from Miami to the Jets
Jets fans were already like I don't know
if he's the best coach has the crazy
press conference with his eyes all over
the place and then they go out there and
listen to this eight points on offense
because they got a pick six 223 yards of
offense 3.4 yards per play since 2000
teams that win the turnover margin four
to nothing were 177 and six on Sunday
the Jets made it a hundred and seventy
seven and seven yeah they have a
mismanaged kicker situation as kid vet
Vick missed an extra point at a field
goal their first eight weeks Westbrook
after after Sunday which they had to win
they faced the Browns the Eagles the
Cowboys and the Patriots twice tough
schedule where do you think we are with
Adam GaSe right now do you have hope
that he's going to turn it around or are
you looking at Monday night against the
Browns and
and this could be bad well I think that
there was a big question after getting
fired in in Miami you know everybody
thought he was just this mastermind
strategist play caller I didn't I didn't
think that I thought what was going on
in Miami didn't look great down there he
didn't show me anything there I think
Sam Darnell is gonna be a good
quarterback I really really do yesterday
he looked like garbage I mean you can't
throw the ball 41 times and complete 28
of them he had five passes batted down
the line of the stretcher deflected but
garbage yet the problem though is is I
the reason I took the bills in the game
was because the Jets offensive line is
really banged up yeah and all the
footage um seeing today they got pushed
around too they did they did be a
desperation game on Monday night where
either the Browns are the Jets are
starting off Owen too and both of those
teams came in with serious playoff
expectation well you got in a game like
that you got a look at talent who has
the most talent right and I think i
think that the Browns have more talent I
also think that they've been a humble a
smack in the face this past week humbles
them they refocus and I think they end
up beating the gym you have been on
teams that have been shellacked yeah
like the Browns were yeah you've
probably been on teams like the Jets
where you've had a lead the whole game
and you blew it
mentally who has the advantage the team
that got beat up for most of the game or
the team that kind of let it slip away I
think the team that it's a good question
I think the team that got beat up most
of the game because you're saying if you
got beat up you're saying listen we got
to be tougher and we got to be more
nasty we got to be more determined we
got to do things a different way than
the way we did it right and we can win
we have the talent to do it now the team
that was up that let her slip away it
was like we were doing everything right
we don't know what the heck happened how
did this happen in will that happen
again
and some points teams that let it slip
away they're always saying man is third
quarter were up by three when is it
gonna be that point where the the
momentum swings the other team when it's
gonna be that point when they they they
just take advantage to me I thought this
just defense was gonna be good this year
when they were they were I mean
listen you ever say forced five
turnovers
Josh Allen really wasn't able to get
anything going nobody threw the ball 37
37 drop backs one sack that's not in
this today's leak that's not gonna be
good enough so the other thing that
happened with the Jets is CJ Mosely went
out in the third quarter when he went
out
Devin Singletary of the bills went on so
the question that I'm gonna have is is
will Mosely be back but I look at the
Browns and jets
both teams have offensive line issues
right now absolutely both teams have
defensive lines that we think should be
able to get after the quarterback
I believe the Browns have better pass
rushers than the Jets the Jets great
defensive linemen are interior guys and
the Jets secondary is a lot worse off
than the Browns the Jets are gonna be
home but either way desperation for
Browns Jetson because they they allow to
come back at home last yesterday so I
mean that doesn't mean very much to me I
just I think usually in these situations
the team that got beat up just a bit got
blown I got embarrassed really that
that's an embarrassment you lose my 30
that's embarrassed is at home first game
of the season that's an embarrassment
you buckle down and you try to figure it
out you figure out a way to go back and
make a statement on the road it really
it's weird where's this game it ended
just right or come nearer so III think
on being on the road probably is a great
thing for the Browns right now they
don't have to worry about the booing
they don't have to worry about the
pressure of being at home showing off
for your fans you kind of sleep in a
different bed a different hotel you can
remain focused yeah this is a good thing
for that for the Browns and now they get
back to zero the it was looking like it
was gonna be rough for Cuyler Murray
yeah and it turned around first-half
calimary six is 16 41 yards and an
interception I'm watching that game and
I'm not gonna lie I feel like I kind of
jinxed him I checked a green check on my
bet Detroit - two and a half they're up
17 nothing they're up twenty four to six
in the 40 oh good a teen feel an amazing
Kyler Murray couldn't do anything the
announcer literally said I would compare
the Cardinals offense to garbage but
that would be an insult to garbage and
then my kid went off yeah
finish the game 1954 for 308 yards
two touchdowns and an interception Kyler
Murray has one of the most beautiful
deep balls that I've seen his throws to
Larry Fitzgerald who God bless Larry
Fitzgerald
he catches everything we know that but
just be able to still run routes for the
last 15 years it's been amazing
fourth quarter its third and 14 he had
Soleri Fitzgerald for a 41 yard catch
they never looked back after that they
found man-to-man all over the field and
I'm looking at Patricia I'm going you're
not getting any pressure right now and
you're running you're rushing to and
you're rushin three I felt like they
were scared to rush him in a weird way I
think they were trying to contain him in
the pocket yeah but by doing that they
allowed him more time to find those
man-to-man matchups but the real the
play that it came down to us Detroit had
the ball late in the fourth and they're
driving they get two first downs they
get one more first down
the game's over it's third down they run
a play where it's like a jet sweep thing
the JD mckissick gets the first down
game over hold on timeout was called
Matt Patricia through Darrell Bevell
called the timeout yeah they had to redo
the play Matt Stafford is shown off
walking off the field going trust me as
in stop calling a timeout
I'll get the play off they get stopped
on third down
Kyler Murray drives down the field
touchdown we're going to overtime
it ends in a tie which sucks bad [ __ ]
hate ties but I leave the game going
calimary is gonna be a baller wait you
leave the game saying you know what he
fought back 13 minutes left in the
fourth quarter they're down 18 18 points
24 six I mean you saying hey games over
it's a wrap he fought back he led his
team we taught my leaders you guys are
gonna say follow me he walks into the
huddle and says listen guys we're coming
back right now we're gonna go down and
score and he wanted to go for it on
fourth down wanted a good time without
us and it's left he was freaking out I
want to tell you how things get ugly for
you look at the possessions first
possession for the Cardinals punt
interception punt
punt punt peel code into the first half
punt punt feel gold-filled go touchdown
touchdown I mean anything that goes
field goal then punt but I mean it just
tells you tails or two halves it also
tells you when you get hot in this
league you can go for a lot of yards and
I think that's what happened with kala
Merri here's the thing they're still
trying to prove that the air raid
offense actually works in the NFL
there's a lot of teams that use pieces
of it here and there but to use it for
the entire game they're still trying to
figure that out they're still also
trying to figure out can a 510
quarterback work in the NFL three of
those passes I mean I saw a bunch of his
passes at least three got batted at the
line of scrimmage I saw that and that
that kind of concerns me just a bit I
didn't think that the Detroit offense
was very good I mean see me defense was
very good coming into the game I thought
that the Arizona Cardinals based on what
they said in the preseason we didn't
show a lot in the preseason we didn't
show these guys too much that they would
come out and do some tricky things some
motions and things like that and they
did and it just didn't work yeah and
there were some throws that Kyler made
that in college would work in the NFL no
no no no yeah the defenders are just too
good the two fasteners hoot all along I
took away from this I think it is
undoubtable that Kyler Murray is going
to be a great quarterback in his League
I'm not worried about his height his zip
that he could throw those out routes
he's he I don't think he's the fastest
thrower in the NFL
I still think mahomes and Allen yeah
great to some of those guys but Kyler's
strength is up there with any of them
number two I would rather the air raid
offense get destroyed in the first half
and come back in the second half because
my question with Kliff Kingsbury and
Kyler Murray is not can you game plan
but can you adjust when I watched
yesterday was the former defensive
coordinator of the Patriots not adjust
as defense which made me think hey
listen you probably weren't the guy in
New England adjusting that defense it
was probably Bill but you came out with
a good first half plan Patricia because
that's what you can do but Bill was an
adjuster with nobody I just like Bill
Beth of course nobody is but if Kings
Barry is able in the first half
to be held 241 yards passing and then
the second half go for 267 well then
guess what that's more valuable the
Cardinals are not going to win the Super
Bowl this year no Cardinals aren't gonna
win the NFC West this year I don't even
know if the Cardinals are gonna win more
games and they lose but if they show
that they have a coaching staff and a
quarterback that can adjust on the fly
that's more valuable than anything
because that means that once you really
start getting it going we'll get better
game plans
Kliff Kingsbury doesn't know how to game
play in the NFL you know yeah he like he
doesn't even know
do I look at last year's tape do I look
at preseason tape he doesn't have
anything to work off of right now for
defenses I don't think their offense
looks at that revolutionary no it's a
lot of spacing but the true thing is
Kyler mary has the arm to challenge you
anywhere on the field and he has the
wheels to scare you and if you have
those two things bro you can stop you
can beat anybody I think that what I saw
out of Kyler was proof that he could be
a guy in this league the question is
will Kyler run a little bit more because
he didn't really run that he wants to I
don't think he wants to and I don't
think coach what he [ __ ] needs to I I
think the same thing with Lamar I think
exactly them to be the ultimate level of
success they have to because Holmes you
taken away darn old why would you do
that if you have the feet you got a
scare him I like the fact that they got
David Johnson going just to be asked not
sure that he was lost
Oh couldn't find him I saw a spray chart
online of where David Johnson got the
ball in week one last year compared to
this year last year it was everything
between the tackles I let this year I
mean he caught a [ __ ] seam route down
the middle for Fiat ammonia's get him in
space that's what he definitely the
couple years ago whenever he had you
know the closer 2,000 yards that's what
he was doing
yeah he was he was in space put him in
space put him in some mismatches was
against linebackers I think this all
offense would do it would do that I'm
wondering can Larry keep this up that's
that has to be a big crush on him you
know the only thought that's easy I'll
say this as an older guy is that first
game is the
it's coming back that next week yeah and
then next week and then next week and
then next week it's just it's just hard
and I'm not saying if anybody could do
it is lyrically but I'm just saying it
gets harder and harder week by week I
think my only surprise that the thing
about Larry is what is he number three
all-time four catches it has to be up
there and he's got like the second
longest streets like Jerry Rice ever he
has played with such shitty quarterbacks
years an entire career the only good one
wasn't Kurt yeah that's it I mean the
amount of Stanton's and other guys that
he's played with then I wonder if he's a
little bit rejuvenated playing with
somebody that's caught it like this
but for him to lay out the way he has
the only thing that's surprising about
Larry is that he is not playing for the
Patriots because I feel like that's the
team where he's gonna end up yeah
they'll never let him go them did they
they had a lot of opportunity to let
Larry go they would never let him go do
you have fun of course man come on hey
it's good to [ __ ] have you in here
the Eagles hey the Eagles the meter
we're ready fire match so you're a five
and I'm a six point four you told me you
love this team yeah Super Bowl you can't
tell me they're going to the Super Bowl
in at six point four right now well this
was before the Malik Jackson injury and
yeah I'm a little bit you're down on
them now I'm not down I'm a six point
four you're a five you're [ __ ] down
on down on the right now because they
didn't start right but you're at six
point four six point four is failing
that's a falling great Brian Westbrook
considers himself a San Francisco 49 I
stopped the worst year of my life we are
recording that we'll talk about that on
the next episode we're recording this on
Monday so we're gonna talk more about
the Monday night games when the podcast
comes out on Thursday and we'll get into
Texan Saints and Raiders Broncos I am
flying to Oakland
I'm gonna red-eye back to record on
Wednesday let's go and I'm not stomping
and you didn't even invite me to Oakland
man well no I got [ __ ] to do bro after
for Brian Westbrook
I am the lef koe man and we will holla
holla holla at you later good luck with
your bets I went three in two in the
super contest the Lions [ __ ] me at a
four in one of course we're gonna have
Westbrook coming up on the Thursday's
pod Warren sharp making you money on
Fridays planet love you guys Mahalo
Chile
[Music]